la recomposición del gabinete es el
culmen de una serie de desentendidos que
vienen de meses atrás se ha adelantado
Petro a una consecuencia Inevitable por
la divergencia de visiones en un pacto
tan diverso
y Rodrigo Muchas gracias yo creo que el
presidente está siendo valer su
condición precisamente de mandatario de
Colombia ha hecho una reorganización
importante en su gabinete ha tratado
Pues de tener gente más cercana a su
propia manera de pensar y de ver el país
y sin duda creo que a pesar de que no se
ha cumplido el primer año el primer año
pues eh Petro con esta decisión nos
demuestra que no está dispuesto a ceder
en su agenda de cambio que fue
principalmente con la que llegó a ser
presidente en la el pasado junio de 2022
y con el cambio de ministros intuye un
gabinete más hacia la izquierda pero sin
el apoyo del partido conservador y de la
u y la división que se intuye dentro del
partido liberal podrá el gobierno formar
mayorías o buscará ahora gobernar más
por decreto
Yo creo que el gobierno intentó formar
mayorías con la inclusión de estos tres
partidos vía fotos burocráticas pero
Petro no es un hombre que esté dispuesto
a esperar demasiado tiempo para lograr
lo que se propone en su cambio y en este
momento pues está demostrando que si los
partidos no están dispuestos a negociar
con él en el aprobación de sus reformas
pues está dispuesto a buscar otras vías
por ejemplo empezar a impulsar la
democracia publicitaria o finalmente
cerrar filas en el congreso y ver cómo
puede avanzar por fuera del legislativo
vía por ejemplo el plan Nacional de
desarrollo o las facultades que podría
tener de luz del ejecutivo respetando
por supuesto los marcos institucionales
y constitucionales de Colombia
no podría esto llevar entonces a un
desgaste mucho más rápido del ejecutivo
antes de acabar su mandato
sin duda yo creo que era esperable que
esto pasara en el primer gobierno de
izquierda en Colombia Porque eso
significa Pues que el estatuto cubo
colombiano es muy difícil de mover y
todo un bloque de orden conservador que
se iba a poner a los cambios que Petro
pues propone desde que está en campaña y
durante toda la trayectoria política que
ha tenido sin embargo yo creo que el
presidente se está jugando el todo por
el todo a tratar de cumplir las promesas
que hizo en campaña hizo también es
loable porque finalmente pues no podemos
caer en un tipo de gatopartidismo de de
cambiar para no cambiar nada Y en este
momento Petro Está tratando de jugar una
estrategia que ya jugó cuando fue
alcalde de Bogotá de la capital de
Colombia y fue un poco tener gente más
cercana que le da un poco mejor lo que
él quiere para el país y tratar de
celebrar la agenda de reformas porque
sin duda la burocracia colombiana y el
estatus quo colombiano hace muy difícil
cambiar algunas cosas Obviamente el
desgaste es notorio y no llevamos ni
siquiera un año de gobierno pero creo
que después de que se agotaron las vías
de diálogo con los partidos políticos
pues se tensa un poco más la cuerda con
ellos y finalmente tendrán que decidir
si salen o no de la coalición de
gobierno y en ese sentido Pues el
presidente hace revalidar el hecho de
que quien ganó en las elecciones pasadas